kommst du gleich wir wussten dass etwas
gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu einem
ja ich habe heute weiblich unterstützung
und zwar ist jenny dabei ja wir machen
heute zusammen ein wirklich geniales
video was sagst du nicht du kannst dich
nicht hinsetzen und zwar habe ich ja in
letzter zeit öfter einfach nur sachen
ausgefragt und viele haben gesagt ich
sollte auch unbedingt noch hier was
anderes machen deswegen bist du jetzt
sie wirklich eine person die mir was
anderes machen darf ich fühle mich
geehrt und zwar haben wir uns folgendes
überlegt mir richtig gut ich musste sie
erst ein bisschen überzeugen davon weil
sie am anfang war es so hammer idee aber
zum schluss hat sie mich auf jeden fall
überzeugt also es ist auf jeden fall
dran bleiben weil sowas hat so was
krasses habt ihr noch nie gesehen genau
ist aber nicht meine idee habe ich also
es gibt schon aber wir machen heute
gesundes du hast es um gesundes essen
sozusagen also wir haben hier sonne
aber wir haben hier auch teller so wir
haben hier eine schüssel und hier sind
jetzt verschiedene buchstaben drin
das heisst also jetzt auch mal für euch
zu erklären jeder von uns die gleiche
abwechselten buchstaben das ist dann
irgendein buchstabe und dann kannst du
dazu noch einen zettel ziehen da steht
dann gesund oder ungesund auf wenn du
gesund siehst musste dass gesundes
produkt davon essen und dein nachbar
also ich in dem fall dass ungesunde
produkt wer ist mein nachbar ich bin ein
nachbar
okay okay okay aber verstanden hab ich
verstand würd ich sagen wie lange
angeschlagen und fangt ihr euch mal an
steigt auch auf jeden fall jennys kanal
ab und das video und ich mache mir auch
noch ein video für jenny was aber noch
nicht fertig stunden video ja also es
geht noch bis morgen um
13 ich gehe da nicht mit okay okay dann
würde ich sagen
allerdings passt also was man von dieser
große zettel der sie hatten und hier
warten wo jetzt die genau erst musst du
von rechts ziehen und dann von christoph
b der buchstabe b haben wir das
mitbekommen
nein ok dann jetzt musst du noch mal ich
hatte ja einen buchstaben vertauscht tut
mir leid
und jetzt darfst du direkt das genau auf
die andere seite ziehen sich einfach
noch eine zweite schüssel meiner nimmt
jetzt dringend kämpfen so gesund nämlich
jetzt haben wir zwei verschiedene sachen
gekauft aber gesund und ungesund und was
das ist wird er jetzt hier auf dem
teller
wir haben ja viele verschiedene sachen
einmal auf ja denn ich muss nochmal
studierte management und das ist das
gesund ja und das hier darf es nicht
gewöhnt
alex hat auch die komische auffassung
dass sowas wie waffeln oder schokolade
gesund sind nein ich habe nur gesagt
waffen sind jetzt nicht so ungesund und
die schokolade ist cuxhaven ist es her
dass es schlimmer wird sich das fett
kohlenhydrate und zucker aber bei der
schokolade ist ja kokos dazwischen
kokosnuss wenn die das frisch glücks
oder so ist es jetzt ja auch so sind
oder fokus und jetzt doch gesund aber
wir müssen eigentlich so eine grenze
ziehen was man mindestens essen muss
davon weiß
du musst zweimal arbeiten ist nicht so
gut jetzt mal probieren ja dass die sind
echt lecker also zwei mal abreißen
nein so richtig rein weil ich zumindest
uns ist das hier ist wirklich das solo
lauf hast du in deinem leben schon mal
auf vergessen überhaupt ich würde aber
auch probieren gleich gut
warum sind durch das schmeckt wie eine
zwiebel und ein bisschen wie groß darf
ich mal auf einer probiert aber es
schmeckt mir jetzt nicht so gut aber
soviel snack für zwischendurch
jahresverlauf das ja hallo okay gut das
haben wir nicht noch einmal leisten
dann würde ich sagen mach mal weiter mit
dem nächsten jetzt hab ich nämlich
ziehen also als nächstes haben wir hier
also wns personen oder ungesund dass wir
jetzt klar aber nicht vermieten so
ungesund ist ungesund ungesunde hast du
wieder gesund ja ich hoffe du hast
wassermelone und was hast du doch mit
der wassermelonen gebrauch gemacht
ich esse immer so du hast so das gibt
auch in meinem geschmack da würde ich
sei also ohne scheiß eine wassermelone
hat auch schon viel zucker drin nein
natürlich bisher sicher fruchtzucker hat
es ist gesund besteht nur das wasser
also laufwerke war besonders das ja aber
es ist trotzdem gesund meinte krieg alle
drei wochen auf einen hund die zweite
war schon schwierig
und wie kostet es jetzt ist alles aus
dem mundraum und was kannst du gut
dauert jetzt nur fünf minuten kannst du
gleich was macht ist noch eine melone
mit solchen 10 und kaffee netz ungesund
wird diese doch ich habe jetzt endlich
mal die waffeln aufgegessen
wir haben ein genie und rang zwei das
hat dsk mehr
jenny hat ganz vorn gezogen und zwar hat
es nicht was zugezogen
als neue funktion und das heißt ich habe
jetzt erdbeeren wobei ich auch als wir
eben die erdbahn ich finde das sind
nicht schön erdbeeren muss ich sagen
guck mal wie die aussieht wie sehen so
ein bisschen so gar nicht so frisch aus
resse als würden wir das schon seit
vorgestern liegen vielleicht wird das ja
auf jeden fall hatte ich sie eben schon
gefragt ob er denn wirklich so gesund
sind weil ich glaube erst mal sind jetzt
auch nicht das gesündeste ich habe
bewusst gesund mir wurde beitrag alles
was lecker ist ist ungesund und erst mal
sind wir schon gut da würde ich sagen
dann esse ich jetzt noch immer mit guten
gewissen die gesunden erdbeeren auf dem
bin ich ganz sicher ob mir schmeckt oder
nicht
manchmal einfach mal was alles passiert
wenn du deine gilt ja ja nein du bist
dran mitziehen
also ich fand das war jetzt schon nicht
schlecht also wirklich wahr oder außer
der lauf der lauf war schon aber es
kommt auf jeden fall noch was kannst du
uns sagen ja es wird jetzt kann ich
hoffe ich hier steht ungesund drauf aber
das ist nicht so schlimm wie der lauf
also ich hoffe
wunderschöne rucola-salat ich es immer
so bitzer mit also ich es kannst du
diese pizza hut mit rucola und tomaten
so ist ein paar mit sagen parmesan gehe
ich als die nur mit druck also dann man
mit rucolasalat für mich super da kann
man nur rucola salat ist schon nicht so
lecker oder das kann ich auch einen
balken und vom baum ist wenn das so
machen warum also woran liegt es
eigentlich dass du bist ja
ernährungsexperte und weil er ist ganz
schön ist das zeigt eigentlich dann mit
nach hause
marco codemasters hat heute zeigen was
du hast habe ich gerade und weißt du
geredet was sie kriegen wir geschmolzen
ja irgendwie schon könne man das aber
ist nur los
das aber nicht oder so gut für deine
idee woran liegt es dass zum beispiel
manche sachen ist auf so den speiseplan
von uns schaffen wie zum beispiel rucola
aber man könnte ja oder so könnt ihr
auch von jedem baum die blätter nehmen
die schmeckt auch das würde ich nicht
unbedingt sagen
doch ich habe als kind schon öfter mal
so irgendwie dass man halt von soja von
aaron baum so ein blatt ist oder auch
mal im gras im grashalm ist dass ich
finde es schmeckt genauso
theoretisch könnte ich auch auf meine
rucola putzen gras fraß wer mit rufen
das ist schon okay du bist wieder daran
kann auch sein
prp ein bisschen schokolade haben stellt
sich heraus ob es lecker wird oder halt
obwohl die schau mal rein ich hier von
der video idee erzählt meine sie macht
das nicht weil sie auf diät ist werden
wir doch ja ja ja wir haben hier paprika
und mini pc die auch überhaupt nicht
zeigen willst du die nicht voll
schneiden nicht wenn du wirst kannst du
dir noch hinterfragt die pizza lang war
schon nicht bezahlen
die waren ja die ist auch kalt im jahr
wenn wir jetzt drauf los frankreich
spricht auf dem fahrzeug zu sagen ist
das gesündeste von allen sachen die wir
jetzt geschlagen dann auch noch da bin
ich ja 200 dem letzten bus dann sah ich
würde sagen eine runde geht noch wir
haben hier
nein ok jetzt wird es ein bisschen eklig
weil das war mich nicht und ich habe
gesunden wir haben hier jetzt zu guter
letzt 2 ingo spezialitäten ich wusste
bis eben nicht dass es irgendwas spitzen
gibt die war steuer die ab 5 euro 99
gekostet jetzt irgendwann mit mit der
schokolade ist das sowieso irgendwann
kannst du mal näher rücken okay das hat
er nicht verloren bei einer
kohlenhydraten wie erd- oder und kreis
besteht einfach nur aus zucker
ok ja es tut mir doch was kann da nichts
passieren
leute das so wir haben hier gerade jetzt
beim küssen kampfgefährten folgendes
problem was war trainer musste die
irgendwas spitze essen die überhaupt
nicht schmeckt ich musste das training
wasser trinken wer mir auch überhaupt
nicht schmeckt sodann ich dann aber aus
gezwungen dann habe ich dieses ding da
gegessen was ich ganz lecker vorankommen
essen dann dachten wir das video ist
vorbei ich gucke mir die kamera andré
die um kamera war einfach aus die ist
genau aussehen hat sich denn irgendwas
betrogen haben dann bin ich runter
gegangen habe neuen ingolstadt gegen
moritz damit wir es halt einfach nochmal
drehen können und ich bin irgendwann
trinke und jenny dieses ding ist und
wenn die weidehaltung so richtig erst
das nicht nur einmal
dann musste sie es wieder essen und dann
war das video wieder vorbei ich gehe zur
kamera gucke kamera aus diese kamera
prächtigen wie die ganze zeit ab jetzt
viel komischer weise wieder auf jeden
fall haben wir jetzt hier den dritten
ingolstadt und jenny weigert sich jetzt
die weltberühmten irgendwas spitzen zu
essen was ist so ekelhaft leute ich kann
nicht das ist doch nicht so ekelhaft
kriegst du jetzt irgendwas wird noch mal
haben der dritte schon ausgerichtet
hier legen was nützen aber ein goldring
und einfach weil ich heute noch mal ich
habe eben nämlich die ich lass dir was
immer ich hab eben irgendwann spitze mit
dem ingolstadt runtergespült ersten
autos schon heute meine fünfte spitzen-
und das ist mein dritter irgendwas
stoppen ich glaube nicht dass es gesund
ist so viel ingwer zu trinken oder schon
nächste woche soll und ich hab auch über
ist die kopfschmerzen ich weiß nicht ob
das auch vom wetter kommen vom engadin
verstecken dann kommt ja super
das video perfekt abschließen eigentlich
wenn man das stunde fertig geworden aber
ich war hat seitdem zweimal im regen
weil ich hätte ja ich hatte ja auch beim
ersten mal direkt mehrere ihm was mit
dem handy habe ich vergessen
naja ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen
damit dass damit gemacht dass lassen
daran um da und schreibt auch gern mal
weitere personen in die kommentare mit
denen ich das noch mal machen soll ich
mache natürlich auch wieder noch mal mit
dir aber klären von jenny auch die wie
das video ab was wir gedreht haben und
den kanal und abonniert gern mal 2 kanal
alex so denn natürlich auch schon
abonniert hast oder wir wollen es noch
klare aktiv geraubt wie gesagt das war
es von uns das ist jetzt zum dritten mal
das ende ich hoffe die kamera läuft noch
gerade falls nicht dann das ist mir auch
egal